[Musique]
ah oui le conseil mais samedi un truc
mais c'est la salle dans koh lanta juste
avant la salle du trésor
non juste après qu'ils mangent de vieira
sous terre le conseil municipal est une
assemblée qui se réunissent en général
une fois par mois ou tout au moins une
fois par trimestre pour adopter des
délibérations qui régissent les affaires
de la commune
c'est un peu comme un conseil de classe
où le conseil des ministres autour de la
table on retrouve donc les conseillers
municipaux de la majorité et de
l'opposition
on savait hélas pour qu'ils nous allons
voter aux municipales
cette table est plus ou moins grande
puisque le nombre de conseillers dépend
de la taille de la commune
en tout cas ce sont eux qui représentent
les habitants et le grand gourou de la
séance et bien c'est le maire c'est lui
qui fixe l'ordre du jour la date l'heure
et le lieu du conseil municipal via une
convocation
celle ci est d'ailleurs communiquer à
tous les conseils municipaux ainsi
qu'aux habitants au moins cinq jours
avant le jour j
enfin on vous l'envoie pas par courrier
un s'est affiché à la mairie
c'est au cours de ce conseil municipal
qu'on vote le budget qu'on décide des
travaux des impôts locaux ya gaye et
qu'on gère le patrimoine communal et
toutes les décisions concernant la
gestion communale alors si l'adrénaline
des conseils de classe où l'anc et bien
sachez que vous pouvez même y assister
et oui sauf exception le conseil
municipal est ouvert au public
alors si vous souhaitez voir en chair et
en os les élus n'hésitez pas à vous y
rendre
sur ce je vous donne rendez vous la
semaine prochaine pour un nouvel épisode
en attendant n'oubliez pas de me poser
vos questions aux adresses ci-dessous